♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, THE PERCENTAGE
OF FOREIGNS BORN IN THE UNITED
STATES IS THE HIGHEST IT'S BEEN
IN THE CENTURY.
IT'S STILL RISING IN ANY CASE.
67 MILLION AMERICANS SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT
HOME.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON IS FINE WITH THAT.
THE NUMBER RISING.
BUT WHAT WOULD THE EFFECT BE IF
WE DID THAT?
WHO IS COMING HERE?
WHAT ARE THEY LIKE?
AND WHERE IS ALL OF THIS GOING?
STEVEN, JUST THE FIRST OBVIOUS
OBSERVATION.
PEOPLE WHEN I WAS A KID USED TO
CARE ABOUT OVERPOPULATION.
I GUESS NOBODY DOES ANYONE.
>> THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
IMMIGRATION BY 2060 WILL ADD 75
MILLION PEOPLE TO THE U.S.
POPULATION.
YOU WOULD THINK PEOPLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT, TRAFFIC,
POLLUTION WOULD THINK ABOUT
THAT.
>> Tucker: BUT THOSE ARE REAL
CONCERNS, WHICH I WILL ADMIT, AS
A KID, I MOCKED THE LIBERALS FOR
HAVING.
BUT AS I GET OVER, I REALIZE I
DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN A CROWDED
PLACE.
DOES ANYONE ON THE LEFT STILL
SAY THAT?
>> THERE ARE A FEW PROGRESSIVES
OUT THERE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF PROGRESSIVE
SUPPORT AND THEY TEND TO FOCUS A
LOT ON POPULATION GROWTH.
BUT MOST MAINSTREAM PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT DON'T TOUCH IT WITH A
10-FOOT POLE BECAUSE LONG-TERM
IT'S NEW IMMIGRANTS AND THE
CHILDREN THEY HAVE.
AND SO THEY DON'T WANT TO TOUCH
THE ISSUE ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION?
>> ABOUT 95% OF THE INCREASE IN
THE U.S. POPULATION WILL COME
FROM FUTURE IMMIGRANTS AND THE
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
THEY'LL HAVE.
>> Tucker: SO THAT'S ALMOST A
COMPLETE TURNOVER IN POPULATION.
>> NO, THAT'S POPULATION GROWTH.
SO MOST OF ALL THE INCREASE IS
COMING FROM IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: SO THE LANGUAGE
NUMBERS ARE REALLY INTERESTING
TO ME.
ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE LIVING IN
THIS COUNTRY DOES NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AT HOME.
HAS IT EVER BEEN THAT HIGH?
>> IT'S HARD TO SAY, BUT IT MAY
HAVE BEEN THAT HIGH AMOUNT PAST.
WHAT'S EVEN MORE INTERESTING OR
PERHAPS MORE TROUBLING IS HOW
CONCENTRATED IT IS.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF AREAS
WHERE 95% OF THE PEOPLE OR 85%
OF THE PEOPLE AND 95 AND 85% OF
THE KIDS IN SCHOOL SPEAK A
FOREIGN LANGUAGE AT HOME.
ONE WONDERS HOW ASSIMILATION CAN
WORK WITH THAT LEVEL OF
IMMIGRATION AND FOREIGN LANGUAGE
CONCENTRATION?
>> Tucker: SO WHAT ARE, BROADLY
SPEAKING, THE EDUCATION LEVELS
OF IMMIGRANTS COMING HERE?
>> IT VARIES.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE IT DOES.
>> 80% PLUS OF IMMIGRANTS FROM
INDIA COME WITH A COLLEGE DEGREE
OR MORE.
>> Tucker: SO HOW DOES THAT
BREAK DOWN?
WHAT PERCENTAGE FOR IMMIGRANTS
ARE COMING WITH NO EDUCATION
VERSUS THOSE COMING WITH HIGH
DEGREES OF EDUCATION?
>> RIGHT NOW SOMEWHAT OVER A
FOURTH OF ALL IMMIGRANTS HAVE
LESS THAN A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION WHEN THEY COME.
A LITTLE OVER A FOURTH ALSO HAVE
NO MORE THAN A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION.
SO A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION OR
LESS IS A LITTLE OVER HALF.
A LITTLE LESS THAN HALF IS SOME
COLLEGE OR EVEN COLLEGE AND
MORE.
>> Tucker: SO THE MAJORITY HAVE
HIGH SCHOOL OR LESS.
>> AND WE KNOW THE WELFARE USE
AND POVERTY IS QUITE HIGH.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL, YOU JUST HEARD, AS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, MANY OF THEM
LOW SKILLED, HALF, CONTINUE TO
ENTER THIS COUNTRY, AN OBVIOUS
QUESTION ARISES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR OUR
ECONOMY, FOR AMERICA'S WORKING
CLASS?
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A DEBATE OVER
WHAT AUTOMATION IS GOING TO DO
LONG TERM.
EVERYONE AGREES IT WILL
ELIMINATE A LOT OF JOBS THAT WE
CURRENTLY THINK OF AS REAL JOBS.
THEY'LL BE GONE.
BUT IS THERE ANY SCENARIO IN THE
FUTURE AS WE PERCEIVE IT NOW
WHERE YOU WOULD WANT THEM TO
HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL THE --
DIPLOMA OR LESS?
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT
THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S A CONCERN.
I THINK IT'S ONE AMONG MANY.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS WE'RE DOING THAT REALLY
HURT LESS SKILLED WORKERS.
THE WAY WE APPROACH IMMIGRATION
AND EDUCATION.
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT EDUCATION
FOR LESS-SKILLED WORKERS.
WE SAY COLLEGE FOR ALL.
AND IF YOU DON'T COMPLETE
COLLEGE, YOU FELL OUT SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE WAY.
>> Tucker: SO WHY WOULDN'T YOU
IF, IF YOU WERE THINKING
THOUGHTFULLY, IF YOU STARTED
WITH THE PRESUMPTION THAT SOME
IMMIGRATION IS GOOD, THAT'S
WHERE I START ANYWAY.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU BE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT LETTING IN MORE PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY HAVE THE EDUCATION THAT
YOU THINK YOUR ECONOMY REQUIRES?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD
DO.
MOST ECONOMISTS WOULD LOOK AT
THE ISSUE AND SAY IF YOU WANT TO
BENEFIT WORKERS AT THE BOTTOM
AND THEIR WAGES, PRETTY MUCH THE
MODELS SAY HIGH-SKILLED
IMMIGRATION IS GOOD FOR
LOW-SKILLED WORKERS.
MORE LOW-SKILLED WORKERS JUST
ADDS MORE COMPETITION TO THE
MARKET.
>> Tucker: I'VE HAD THIS DEBATE
OVER A HUNDRED TIMES ON THIS
SHOW OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
AND THEY SAY, ALL THE STUDIES
SAY THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> I'M NOT AWARE OF A STUDY THAT
SHOWS THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDIES THAT
SHOW THE MIX OF IMMIGRANTS
REFLECTS ROUGHLY WHAT'S IN THE
POPULATION.
SO THAT'S OKAY.
BUT THAT'S THE WRONG QUESTION TO
ASK.
THE QUESTION TO ASK WOULD WHICH
WOULD BE BETTER.
GIVEN TO HAVE HIGH-SKILLED
IMMIGRATION, IS IT GOOD TO HAVE
A LOT OF LOW-SKILLED OR LESS?
AND WHAT YOU WOULD SAY IS THE
LESS LOW-SKILLED IMMIGRATION YOU
HAVE, BETTER THINGS WILL BE FOR
THE LOW-SKILLED WORKERS THAT ARE
HERE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU COULD DO ONE
THING TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO REAP THE BENEFITS
OF OUR ECONOMY, WHAT WOULD IT
BE?
>> WELL, I THINK CONCEPTUALLY WE
HAVE TO VALUE WORK AND SAY IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT CONSUMPTION AND
HOW CHEAP STUFF IS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO REALIZE IS
THAT PEOPLE HAVING WORK IS
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO THEM.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
PAYING EVERYBODY OFF WITH THREE
GRAND A MONTH WON'T BE THE
ANSWER?
>> NO, IT'S A DISASTER.
IT'S A GREAT ANSWER FOR THE
FOLKS DOING WELL.
THE FUNNY THING IS, THE HIGHER
UP THE INCOME LADDER YOU GO, THE
MORE PEOPLE SAY, OH, NOT
EVERYONE NEEDS A JOB.
YOU GO DOWN TO THE BOTTOM END OF
THE LADDER, PEOPLE SAY, WE WANT
THE JOBS, BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW CRITICAL WORK IS
TO THEIR FAMILIES, THOUGH THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AND IF WE DON'T FOCUS ON THAT,
IF WE JUST SAY, OH, WE'LL GROW
THE PIE, WHAT THEY SAY, WE'LL
JUST SEND EVERYONE A PIECE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BAKE YOUR OWN
PIE.
WE'LL JUST GIVE YOU A SLICE.
THAT'S NOT A MODEL FOR A GOOD
SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: THAT USED TO BE
OBVIOUS.
>> IT DID UNTIL ABOUT THE MIDDLE
OF THE CENTURY.
AS LONG AS PEOPLE HAVE MORE
STUFF EVERY YEAR, WE'LL CALL
THAT SUCCESS, BUT THAT'S NOT